all right I'm going to begin sewing this
now some of you might notice a an issue
with the way I felt this as I here -
that's fine
by the end if I stop and you let it go
put it all with it then you control this
but so now to stay with you all of it I
do it 10 - x equals root 3 now this is
again another exact value sort of
intending to think you can muck with it
even if you had something missing this
time that's not what I'm focused on so
I've hopefully included my one two root
three triangle to help you recognize
which angle is the first angle that will
give you a solution to this it's going
to be 60 degrees baculum eye-hand 60 is
opposite on a dresser that's Route three
on one
okay so I can say 2n equals 60 degrees
noticing that I've got a 2x amendment
max and there's another solution at
least do a man usually I get pairs of
solutions when I did my normal domain
Orchestra to please the period of 10 is
every 180 degrees right so not only
should that be a solution but this 1208
will also be a solution okay so far so
good
alright so I've got two solutions
there's nothing wrong with what I've
done so far but of course I haven't
finished solving you see I've got 2x
over here and what I really want is X so
therefore if I go from here divided by 2
now I'm going to go from here and TR and
also divide by 2 so these are two
solutions and these solutions are right
they just not the only one okay so I
want you to remember I asked you I made
a point of asking what kind of
modification of this of the original
tree function is this and you said to me
it with our frequency change right now
can 2x is it more frequent or less
frequent than the regular 10 graph more
frequent right instead of one copy of
the graph from north 180 you're again
going to get two copies of the graph
from north to 180
which is why CEC solutions do you see
there between knots and 180 look you've
already got two solutions when you've
got an angle that's 180 degrees but the
grass doesn't just stop it gets
compressed but it gets more and more
copies so if there are two solution T in
between and remaining lesser represent
between north and 180s then it says to
reason if the original chain graph was
periodic every other engineer degrees
and this guy which is twice and records
is periodic every 90 degree so therefore
I'm gonna get more copies between
between 180 and 360 okay so that's fury
of my degrees you can see look there's a
gap nine degrees right so in addition to
these guys I'm going to go a 90 degree
again and then I'm going to go to green
one more time and have an awkward number
of boards in this okay and this is what
the actual solution is there are four
points are we this graph intersects with
as you can throw it if you like but it
is just a bit repetitive so don't do it
so how can I work out a more systematic
way of solving a champion which is not
just going to help us here but we'll
also have this for the next questions
you know about frequency but there's a
similar issue here's what I would
suggest waiting if written down this is
like a first line like I have okay it's
pretty standard procedure to not just
write the equation solving but also this
domain you're solving it now because
we're solving within the same domain
over and over again I get it if you can
read it down like I haven't have been a
bit lazy but this time I do it because
I'm going to help you see something here
that will be useful for you if I'm
solving for x between laundry then for
2x I'm actually solving in a broader
domain here's how you can see that
remember from this line to this line
what I did was I divided by two
like so right we're slowly therefore in
tune X then you can take everything here
in the survey and multiply by two
they're just sort of reverses right so
much up to X in the middle when you
double be ready go
so here after in that's fine but when
you double 360 you get 720 so actually
you should be thinking from this line I
should will be just solder from north of
350 I should actually be solving from
north to 720 and that means that at this
point you recognize its weight is not
just suit solution this guy goes for a
really long time you get more solutions
you get this guy and you get this guy
there's still between not and 720 so
there's still legitimate solutions if
you're solving 10 2x log 10 X you've
recognized all four solutions but then
of course you don't want to talk to X
you want to solve for X so u / - just
like we did before and there's your four
solutions does that make sense
so maybe you want to do to come to a set
of 20 things and put a box around it and
what I want you to label as like what
are you doing here
recognize the changed domain
okay this is a really really common
paper students to that month up because
we're grateful to love the 360
impression sovereigns not drifting into
your boots your to the page right but
when you modify the function like this
where you modify the domain as well so
let me show you how to get a look at the
next one come for what is this a site is
sign right yes okay so they cannot hold
your name through it so you can't let
you you can work out what's going on
with me okay I'm going to right now the
domain the domain is Norton 360 sure
okay so I'm falling for X between non
360 but that means if I'm solving
actually this guy it will be X minus 250
I thought to take all of them and I'm
going to subtract 250 so in the middle I
have X minus 2 picking up on I'm
actually solving one so a 16-2 250
Thank You chef and off on the last year
I've got negative 200 so this is what
I'm actually solving okay so keep this
in mind keep it sort of tucked in the
back of your hand now when you look at
the actual equation you're solving for
root 3 on 2 that's a nice convenient
angle what's the first time to get a
solution for that
Thanks exact value top triangle there
sure is given 60 degrees right opposite
on hypotenuse gives you rich reality so
60 around that data 10 so I'm going to
write down X minus 260 degree the first
solution I expect is 60 now think from
it it is in our modified remember to
check out it's okay it that's fine now
normally what would we do well we would
look at normally we would say oh it's
not a 3pt so you enjoy a wrap from
multiplicity you're saying what
solutions have I got let's say that
money is so I've gotten this solution
and then what would you do what would
you do from there you take 60 degrees my
first solution watch my next one over
there look at the symmetry of the graph
if you went forward from 0-60 degrees to
get the first remission look at the
symmetry of that firstly set that's it
so you've gotta get the other solution
by going backwards 64 180 right your
next solution B would be 120 degrees
that's normally what you would say right
but I'm not going to say it this time
can someone tell me why 120 degrees is
outside this domain right so it's not
going to be a solution for this so I'm
not going to write 120 in fact what I'm
going to do is recognize that this is
the real domain hundred right from
negative 250 to 110 this time do what
you draw this distracted bill to 360 so
I'm going to stop drawing it there at
110 degrees that's how far my graph
actually goes and now it's going to go
to the left negative 250 degrees second
to look like let's see if I'm going to
get at least that much
how fun is that hey that's go be
negative 180 right and then I'm gonna
have to go pretty sure a little bit more
like that okay I don't get quite to the
stationary point if anyone know why
where's the stationary point now it's a
10 point it's negative 270 isn't and I
haven't haven't got there okay so I've
stopped a bit short right so route 3 on
C remember I got my first solution over
here so I'm going to look backwards and
I'm gonna say how am I going to get that
solution I'm going to find that
[Music]
it's a tricky mr. Klassen thought what
can give you the answer yet seeing look
at the graph how would you break it out
at this point without myself when you're
unemployed
okay so negative 180 is here agree right
now one of the ways we could get a
solution like this one that was busted
over here
with 180 takeaway 60 that would have
given a solution except is outside the
domain okay
that's at 1/8 will if I go back exactly
360 degrees that will take me to
negative one is as going to suggest why
it's going backwards 360 degrees
why is that give me a legitimate
solution 360 what's special about 360
it's a full revolution the period of
science right so if you got a solution
here at 120 you'll get another solution
360 degrees from for red before which is
minus 220 you're great
do you see within the domain and we
qualify it right it's just with you just
like our other solution with John Alden
so we abandoned 120 we said forget that
but if you go back 360 degrees you'll
get another solution
in fact the period of silence I will it
take to get full copy so one point was
the solution
so is this done better right do you may
even like to write down the way I got
this was 120 degrees minus 360 degrees
okay if I was to I figure the other
direction too I figure 120 plus 360 I
get more solution right you can always
go backwards and forth between the
pieces okay good
are there any other solutions that are
going to be within the summit the edges
go tiny look how do you something you
argued
yes sir because you're like okay good
like I've gotten to the edge with most
two point is right next to this and
sixty is pretty already worked out I
can't get any more solution this way
another way you could argue it is just a
look at your rap right my grab is not
very good but it's good enough to show
so one two solution I'm not I'm
definitely not going to get one
in-between condoms right I have sold to
Xbox 360 I don't really want it most TTC
I really want X so what am I going to do
to website I'm going to actually cooking
group so that gives me three hundred and
ten or ten degrees both of which are in
the original domain for X okay